someone running upstairs on all fours
would give me the ick strongly disagree
I think it's funny I'm just gonna go
upstairs do not think it would be the
funniest thing so say somebody's like
who's going upstairs and they did it on
you thought it was on ironic and they
like a day later they'd be like you know
that was a joke that would be hilarious
that would be you would married that
[Music]
so how do we think we're going to fair
today agree
disagree I think we be quite similar I
think we I do I
agree being good at bowling is really
embarrassing oh it was really
embarrassing being really good at I
cannot imagine what you're like strongly
disagree I disagree that it's
embarrassing so we're after a flyer what
about what about the shoes the Sho it's
embarrassing
shoes tell me what they want know is
what you were like on a bowling lane a
nightmare Absol
absolute and I hate being bad at exactly
so that's why it's anyone who's good at
this bet you're real person turns like
yes oh ex nail on the head and when they
stick the like they stick the railings
up for me do you do I was just going to
ask you do you do the railing because I
don't want to go into the gutter I'd
rather have the railings up and still
get strike than hit that cuz you don't
want to be like you want to be doing
this yeah but I think that's
embarrassing I would rather live without
music than
movies oh my God what a
question I would rather I would rather
live we were talking about this the
other day can you imagine a world where
there was no music I
think that's a horrible question I'd
rather live without music I I I agree
with that no you would have no job oh
you could work stage that's what I was
thinking I was thinking at least you
have the theater which people have
before so for example the people before
the talkis came in so for
example picture this picture this in the
1790s when they were doing this quiz lad
Bible wasn't I knowed until the 18th
century you know you would have had the
theater storytelling but if you didn't
have music I love movies no you love
movies look
and that's tough you love music I love
music I think i' like like I find music
so expressive it's a tentative it's like
it would depend on I'm doing
this
Ouija that's a tough question it is a
really it's a good question yeah
thanks uh always get these GES WR I
would beat the person opposite me in an
arm wrestle oh for God's
sake come on Paul I agree with that
statement
gladi yeah but he's got the the most
outrageous ly nice arms so no but now
after glad I look like his tiny
dad his tiny
Dad yeah yeah okay what about what about
instead rock paper scissors rock paper
scissors 50/50 rock paper scissors rock
paper scissors hold on what do you do
one two three Rock Pap like on the rock
paper scissors okay see already I'm
scared
yes okay next one yeah reset your glass
please Jesus all right someone running
upstairs on all fours would give me the
ick strongly disagree I think it's funny
yeah but are they conscious of us are
they doing it to make laugh let me
quickly go upstairs and was like I'm
just going to go
upstairs that's the but if someone
didn't like do you know what gives me
more of an cuz I think we all do it is
like if you were like I'm just going to
go down and turn off the lights and
they're being all chill and then you
hear them accelerate up the stairs
because they're scared cuz I think we'd
all do it but I think if I was trying to
impress someone I'd like smoothly walk
up the stairs but be dealing with the
[Laughter]
inp could down the stairs and
all that would be weird sorry I was just
using bathroom but would you not think
it would be the funniest thing so say
here somebody's like just going upstairs
and they did it on you thought it was on
ironic and they like a day later they'd
be like you know that was a J that would
be hilarious that would be you married
yeah yeah 100% what about like sliding
down them on your bom that gives me more
of the ick it's not as funny it's just a
bit weird yeah and what you have to sort
of less of a big gesture you be like
it's your bom I've broken my coxic
exactly exactly people with personalized
number plates should be banned from
driving easy does anybody in this room
dis full I what what you R yeah
Gladiator
oh God exact that's that's what I was
going to
do like that that's real cuz obviously
they want somebody to bring it up in
conversation yeah and it's mortifying
and think you'd have to apply for it
you'd have to ring someone up and be
like I just need personalized number
plate yeah this is a priority in my life
yeah yeah I'm going to call somebody
about this yeah set it up change these
ones and then hopefully register it for
the time that I'm getting into my car
that somebody might go it's that
it's Sinister it's absolutely Sinister I
hate
sin it's Sinister it is though it is
it's like a clown no don't laugh at him
he's dead rice it's not funny
no I would rather fight a 100 duck siiz
horses than one horse-sized duck
okay I'd rather fight 100 duck siiz
horses duck size horses or duck size
horse I think I'd prefer or horse sized
dock horse sized dock I'd prefer the
horse sized dock wouldn't you Lo a
little duck sized horses tiny horses
they'd be nimble cuz the so the horse
sized animal is actually a duck yes but
thing to be looking at where how would
you beat it how would you defeat it Paul
I'm trying to deal with this first
question I I think imagine a lot of
little tiny horses every hundred of them
100 of them 100 of them you'd be there
you Ki you got one even actually no cuz
you could just like could St them boot
them yeah you could kick them away of
them though I agree yeah but better than
a massive and it would be much more fun
and Ducks yeah it would be more why
don't we go why don't we go
tinyes tiny duck no yeah so that what
does that mean so that means
we it doesn't really
matter said beat the tiny horse
ballad should be banned from
karaoke karaoke should be banned in my
opinion I'm not a fan of kar either I'm
not somebody always sings a song that's
a bit too serious yeah no this actually
reminds me of him yeah sorry you're all
hammered like you're sitting there
trying to be all yeah yeah yeah well
done amazing brilliant ah bril and also
with karaoke you think when is this
there's a kind of anxiety with k karaoke
which is like is ever going no is it
ever going to end you know what I mean
when my go
though no it's cuz you're in this little
box I just don't like it I've never had
an enjoyable experience there yeah yeah
if you do go what would you sing H I've
got
no I know what you're doing I'm not
going to do
it saying bless you after sneezing is a
waste of time oh I don't agree with that
is a waste of time strongly disagree or
just disagree
uh saying bless you
is now that you say
it like I wouldn't like it is actually
just a waste of time yeah but then you
could say that about manners do you know
what I mean why would say Get It Anyway
manners is has a yeah but some if I was
if I was in a room and I sneezed and you
didn't say bless
you I never said I I never say bless you
do you know I like I don't know what it
is about May it's a bit weird to say
bless you need actually say bless cuz
like think how weird that is is like
it's very religious it bless you bless
you bless you I think it comes from the
plague though they used to say like God
bless you're going to die you're going
to die I knew that I didn't know that no
I didn't know that no I that's why I
moved it from a strongly disagree to a
dis I actually am going to say I agree I
think we shouldn't be doing that anymore
oh wow start a petition yeah start a
petition stop stop person realize this
this is going to send me it's just going
to send me into such exist
essential crises you're welcome I didn't
say thank
you uh roast is the best form of
potato oh chips
chips I what other typ of potatoes are
there like crisp do you like a dolphin
was no it's too fancy it's not fancy
fancy is like the is that the like one
that's of cream no that's garlicky isn't
it you could have a garli big fan of
garlic potatoes mom I think you I think
I could get you into D potatoes
no
yeah I didn't know that I was ever going
to say that sound overtly sexual I could
get yours a do potato you could try I'll
try I never thought I would be saying
that s you today this lighting but are
the mashed potatoes are absolutely
disgusting to me I don't anything unless
it's like like really like whipped and
full of milk no that's absolutely Ely
repulsive to me I'm going to say I I
disagree with it it's not the best
strong but not correct yeah 49% of
people said that roast is the top tier
watch 51 uh chips at second came second
Mash at third were at 10 with 9% of the
vote I didn't even know what they were
to be totally honest you should only
wear a band T-shirt If you know all of
their songs you should only
wear I agree no but what if the T-shirt
like what does it matter if you don't
well like if I had a band with Like
Girls Allowed no I do know most yeah
exactly but like if it's a cool t-shirt
are you're not just going to wear it
anyway with a with a band I wouldn't I
have loads of t-shirts where you're like
that yeah like there's a there's a Faith
No More t-shirt that I wear it's red and
has a dog on I don't know their music do
you know any songs not a single song oh
that is a disagree do you know have a
lot of people going oh F no more I lie
like yeah I love
them yeah yeah yeah yeah these are good
question oh thank you I've got a better
dad joke than the person opposite me
what you call a cat that's swallowed a
lemon is it something to do with meow is
it to do
with
sarus what's SM why did Jenny fall off
the swing
cuz seem Dr cuz someone threw a brick at
her
head it's really not a dad joke I
thought this a good joke good
J uh uh next question there is nothing
romantic about two people sharing a
shower there's nothing romantic what the
in what world wow who thinks does anyone
in the room think there's nothing
romantic about two people sharing a show
romantic what you think is
sexy yeah yeah it can be romantic if
you're playing a bit of Ena in the
background I think it's romantic oh I
think it's really romantic great yeah it
is pretty sexy too yeah sexy and
romantic Logistics though bit tricky
sometimes the what the logistics it can
be can get around yeah yeah of course
you yeah absolutely absolutely yeah okay
sadly this is the last
[Laughter]
one the person opposite me is a joy to
work with oh
sentimental
Lely yeah yeah I would love if somebody
truthfully was really
like can we cut that question please
please uh oh no absolute Joy absolute
Joy easy answer great never go bowling
with them yeah don't go bowling or play
Rock Paper Scissors with fight horses
duck horses horses yeah strongly agree
yeah for sure for
shizel
for Shel
Shel that is
wild that is not going into my body this
morning oh my God that's appalling